c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche de ces jeux tout le temps
qu'ils ne feraient
que nous les gamins qui pouvait nous
rendre fous tous ces fous que tu faisais
n'importe où et n'est pas américain tous
ces gens à qui tu donnes la sourire
l'étude donne d'habitude quand tu t'es
forcément rire et qu'il faut être reste
moi j'ai mes mauvais ça déchire et mama
tu le fais aussi qui fait que me touches
je te le jure
bah jamais doublé
non non
on oublie
oh
non
[Musique]